okay so we're getting into world war ii
hulk and this is an editorial mandate
story there's no way it's anything else
okay those of you guys who are familiar
with comics you know what that is those
are guys who are not usually writers are
given carb launch to kind of write
characters to their own interpretation
there's obvious things they can't do
they can't just indiscriminately kill
spider-man right like that has to be
probably like a main event it's probably
got to go through a lot of approvals
before something like that is done uh
but then sometimes what marvel editorial
will do especially if it's part of like
a bigger picture is they'll go to a
writer and they'll be like you can write
this story however you want to but it
needs to end like this right this
character needs to end this way or it
needs to feature this character at this
level of power or focus largely on this
character or something like that that's
the reason why the phoenix event that
jason aaron did in avengers focus on
echo because an echo tv show was coming
out and marvel wanted to raise the
profile of the character and it's why
this is happening because while i do
love the ending of this story the way we
got there is kind of stupid right so uh
so what you end up doing here is
basically picking up with she-hulk who's
essentially behind like a locked door
just kind of like tethered down going
through a whole bunch of just mental and
and psychic torment right just basically
being tortured being brainwashed that
kind of a thing and so before we find
out what's going on there you actually
jump back to avengers mountain right
tony stark and these guys where gorilla
man just kind of takes off through the
whole place and then basically ends up
uh summoning what is in effect the
winter guard and as soon as they showed
up i was like okay this story is going
to go downhill and it does uh but the
winter guard these guys i mean they're
no one cares about the winter guard
right i mean well no you know what i
take that back dark star is pretty
awesome dark star has the ability to
manipulate dark force energy which is
basically like living darkness
essentially and then you end up getting
crimson dynamo who's kind of cool right
in the rest of the roster now an
important thing to note here is red
widow we still don't know who red widow
is we still don't know anything about
her all we know is that it's a chick
there's a lot of theory and speculation
going on out there that is natasha
romanov that is black widow but we don't
really know for sure a lot of people are
also saying that it's a sister of
natasha romanoff right that she's
basically being brought back or kind of
given a higher profile and things are
going from there we don't necessarily
know what's happening all we know is
that in the midst of all this because of
the fact that
gorilla man has essentially given the
winter guard access to the to avengers
mountain that it allows them to complete
their mission which is to basically
kidnap she-hulk now the argument here is
that they're taking she-hulk because of
damage she had done to moscow at some
point in time basically trashing the
place but crimson dynamo actually ends
up deploying hulkbuster armor which
basically encases uh she-hulk and then
whisks her away right and then the rest
of the winter guard basically just ends
up taking off now of course in terms of
gorilla man and why he did what he did
gorilla man was a guy named kenneth hale
essentially somewhere along the line he
had killed the previous gorilla man and
then was cursed and then became the new
gorilla man himself this guy doesn't
matter this guy's never really mattered
he's never really been why take that
back when he was part of agents of atlas
with jimmy wu he was cool but outside of
that he's never really had any major
relevance in marvel comics so it's
interesting to see that he's here of
course the motivation here seems to be
that he was working with dracula and
dracula said he would give you know
gorilla man what it is that he couldn't
get on his own presumably to kill him
and in fact he says that right he says
that like red widow would kill him
something that he simply can't do he's
basically you know more or less immortal
and in turn red widow's like no that's
not going to happen so she just leaves
him to his fate so he's just kind of
there hanging out but nonetheless at
that point you switch over to she-hulk
herself there's what's essentially a
kangaroo trial going on here right where
it's like a mock trial it's a sham it's
really just kind of being carried out
but the the end result is already
determined in terms of what's gonna
happen of course she's found guilty of
her actions and like attacking moscow
and all that kind of stuff and so you
basically end up finding out that this
place where she's being tormented and
being tortured is the red room now
that's kind of an interesting thing
because the red room itself has been
depicted in different ways over the
years in marvel comics there was a time
when the red room was just a training
facility and indeed it basically is it's
russia's answer to specifically weapon x
the winter guard is kind of their answer
to weapons plus slash the avengers but
uh but but the red room itself is like
their version of weapon x the program
that made wolverine which is a joint
venture between canada's department k or
department h rather and the united
states cia right so it was kind of their
thing but at the end of the day of
course the avengers aren't going to let
one of their own be kidnapped and just
sort of ran off and so they end up
basically tracking everybody down to the
siberian tundra right somewhere not too
far away from the gulag and then you
basically have iron man and captain
america who initially respond they're
able to overcome the the early guards
you know fairly readily and then in turn
she-hulk breaks out of her own facility
and then in turn kind of starts running
amuck throughout the place right like
literally trying to get out trying to
break through but across her at least
during this entire process she keeps
having these crazy visions of like black
widows and things like that so there's a
lot of mental conditioning going on here
right i mean she says like we are widows
right we're omega reds and we're winter
soldiers like we were basically trained
here in the red room we were trained
here and we were made what we are but
then you end up getting this revelation
that the whole perspective of her like
breaking out and escaping that none of
it happened that it's all basically just
this mental torture that she's
experiencing and that what they're
actually doing is they're planting
subliminal messages right kind of a
subliminal mission inside of her own
mind so that at a future point in time
they can use her for their own ends now
the funny thing about this is that in
the midst of all that with captain
america showing up and iron man showing
up that they are able to essentially
hold their own against the winter guard
to a degree and that leads to carol
danvers showing up then of course she's
met by the arrival of dark star so the
two of them fight which is a fight that
nobody asked for and then like carol
danvers ends up asking for help from
thor seemingly so like the only
appearance you get from him is he like
throws his hammer and it knocks out dark
star and that's basically it right so
that's that seems like a colossal waste
of thorpe but the thing about this is
that jennifer walters is constantly
experiencing what is in effect mental
torment right just over and over and
over again mental torment just being
tortured until she really actually does
break out of the facility and then at
that point she's basically in rampage
mode she's not really thinking clearly
she's not really thinking rationally and
so that's where you end up getting the
world war hulk concept i mean if
anything is more like a like a poor
man's world war hulk event right nowhere
near the same level of gravitas or
impact or or meaning in any capacity but
she basically ends up escaping the
facility and there's really not a whole
lot they can do because she's raged out
so much right because she's so hulked
out and then you end up basically
finding out that the actual mission of
of she-hulk once she's deployed at least
as it's stated by uh by red widow is
that one she's now referred to as the
winter hulk is basically what they call
her and two her mission
as it exists is to basically destroy the
atlanteans that's the mission of winter
hulk the winter guard kidnaps she-hulk
brainwashes her to kill the atlanteans
that's that's what happens that's that's
the motivation so as you guys can expect
going through this story uh essentially
once she gets to the kingdom of atlantis
of course gorilla man is there trying to
help her out and you know whatever uh
gorilla man
for the most part gorilla man's actions
here are more like personal atonement
right the desire to kind of make up for
his past misdeeds more so than anything
else the fact that he betrayed the
avengers not just once but a couple
times and the fact that everything that
she hulk is going through is a direct
result of his actions so there's a
little bit of character redemption going
on and so far is what they're trying to
do here the other part of this and this
is something that i hope you guys notice
is that that winter hulk is kind of
almost seems to be a little bit lucid
periodically but basically has this
inner turmoil going in where it's
essentially jennifer walters trying to
overcome her hulk persona now that's the
big difference here and that's where
kind of like the world war hulk element
comes into play right world war hulk it
wasn't really a rampaging hulk that was
beyond any semblance of control it was
just a really really pissed off hulk i
mean like the super angry rampaging hulk
that couldn't be stopped that was hard
of a monster hulk right that was that
was a crazy situation but what goes on
here is essentially this idea of of her
kind of being controlled right now when
it comes to the nature of jennifer
walters as she-hulk that was a big
differentiation between herself and
banner right and the incredible hulk
that the incredible hulk right banner
would turn into the hulk and wouldn't
usually remember what happened right
especially when you were dealing with
savage hulk and savage hulk wouldn't
really know what was going on with
banner with she-hulk it wasn't that way
that jennifer walters could actually
turn into she-hulk at will and she was
totally lucid she would basically
remember everything her incredible whole
persona was more a source of power that
she could tap into as opposed to a
wholly separate personality that would
take over and so that's that's one of
the big differences what you're seeing
here is really more akin to she-hulk
falling closer in line with the
traditional incredible hulk but
literally right like like red widow
tells her her boss she's like yes sir
the asset is on-site locked and loaded
i've never had cause in my life to use
this particular word but if you allow me
sir she is beautiful and her target is
in range no she has no idea of her true
role here or if she does she's too
driven by rage for it to matter the
winter hulk will assassinate the king of
atlantis now the true thing here i guess
it's kind of a misnomer to say she's
there to kill the atlanteans she's
actually there to be a distraction that
the goal of red widow and those guys is
to wipe out all the atlanteans and that
she-hulk is there to just kind of be a
distraction to keep it keep name of the
submariner distracted so they don't
really know what's going on no one
really seems to be fully aware of what's
taking place here and so of course
gorilla man again trying to make up for
his past misdeeds ends up intercepting a
red widow in the water before they can
deliver their bomb to wipe out all the
atlanteans and then of course a fight
breaks out between name with a
submariner and winter hulk which is kind
of weird to see the name of the
submariner is able to go toe-to-toe with
the winter hulk if she really is
amplified in terms of strength and the
fact that she's overcoming him i guess
that's more of a testament of how strong
she is but she's literally able to just
pummel this guy right and then she tells
everybody like she tells all the
atlanteans evacuate your people and then
says avengers assemble and that's when
you basically end up realizing she was
never really under the control of the
winter guard at all right that she had
been taken and seemingly allowed herself
to be taken and that she was being
conditioned and all that kind of stuff
but as somebody who had been an agent of
shield that she was part of the avengers
she'd been part of the fantastic four
that her mental fortitude was so far
beyond the winter guard's ability to
control her that it was all basically a
ruse and once she realized what it was
that they were after that their goal was
to destroy the atlanteans then she
basically snaps back and says okay look
avenger's a symbol right and calls
everybody together and then everything
kind of starts popping off and like thor
shows up and all that kind of cool stuff
you know and they basically end up you
know trying to save the day and whatnot
of course she's able to overcome all
these different forces out there which
is it's kind of interesting to see her
depicted in like this ultra violent high
maddening rage she's able to or at least
able to go toe-to-toe with red shield
for a minute until red she-hulk ends up
injecting herself basically with hulk
blood and then in turn becomes hulk out
herself right so like red widow becomes
the hulk which is you know kind of kind
of interesting they call her the widow
hulk which is kind of weird uh
yeah it's i mean i think it's cool right
that like the hulk becomes the widow i
think it's kind of cool but you know as
the two of them fight and the conflict
kind of goes on and on and on and and so
on and so forth that ultimately uh red
she-hulk gets the upper hand and then
realizes this bomb is about to go off
and it will obliterate all the
atlanteans in the process and so what
she ends up doing is that at the time
when the bomb detonates that she
actually absorbs all the energy of the
bomb as it explodes and then in turn is
just hyper charged with gamma radiation
and then essentially takes off but with
the kind of mental conflict going on in
her own head this idea that she is in
turn trying to wrestle control of the
hulk away right jennifer walters is
trying to regain control of herself that
basically once she steps off and then
quote unquote detonates if you can call
it that and the smoke clears that in
effect she reverts back to classic
she-hulk right the old-school she-hulk
from the john burn days right where she
had like a very slimming figure and like
a great big chest and all that kind of
stuff she ends up reverting back to that
i love seeing that this classic she-hulk
is back i think it's dumb how we got to
this point but she basically ends up
just kind of abandoning her role as an
avenger and then in effect goes back to
becoming a lawyer all this story was
meant to do right the only thing this
story was meant to do was to send
she-hulk back to the version that she
was before because that's the version
you're gonna see in the show that's
basically all it was right to turn
she-hulk into the character that you're
going to see in the tv show and that's
basically it i don't know i normally try
to not crap on comics especially with
something that jason aaron writes
because he's a phenomenal writer this
comic was ass like this story was
terrible it was it was bad just
ridiculously bad i loved the ending but
everything else about it was dumb so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank god and i
will catch you all later
peace